okay now we need to do some work in the
office service class which is in the
service package when you use object fire
to define an entity class you need to
register the entity class you do this in
a static method in offi service see here
this is where we register the profile
class but you're going to need to go
ahead and add the code to register the
conference class you'll probably find
that when you do that you get an error
but the error is quite simply because we
don't have the right import so go ahead
and import the conference class and
that's all you have to do to register
your entity go ahead and pause the video
from in it while you register the
conference class